[Applause]
thank you very much i know why you're
happy today
four states have more states now have
legalized marijuana
and not a moment too soon
uh real i mean almost the whole country
now
and this not only strikes a blow against
the repressive prohibition that has
compromised justice in this country for
way too long
but it significantly expands where i can
tour
oregon how about this oregon
decriminalized coke
meth ecstasy and heroin and experts say
this is a major win for charlie sheen's
cargo shorts
but uh okay so let's see what else is in
the news um
oh yeah uh biden won the
[Music]
oh
election
[Applause]
not that we're taking sides i just
wanted to report that
no matter who you voted for we can all
be proud that we live in the third most
democratic country in north america
um now i don't know i mean it's it's
four we go on at seven to the west ten
to the so we're three hours before this
goes on the other the network's
still are too chicken [ __ ] to call it
but plainly um he's won this election
but you know elections
in america they're a lot like
losing your virginity when you're a
lesbian you know
between the late ballots and the
recounts and the lawsuits and the
electoral college it's hard to actually
know when you're finished
and
now of course until all the ballots are
counted president trump is telling
everyone to stay calm and classy and
respect the process of course he's not
he's throwing a tantrum like the two-ton
whiny little [ __ ] he is
he doesn't like it that for the first
time he's on the other end of an
eviction notice
he doesn't he doesn't like it that he
probably will lose the popular vote by
as much as 7
million biden got the largest percentage
against an incumbent since
fdr looks like the democrat
biden will win georgia georgia
and
and also the most conservative state
ever arizona
arizona yeah
it seems like arizonans like presidents
who don't [ __ ] on john mccain you know
that
it's funny during the week while they're
counting and all these different states
that are still out trump's goons
were outside the counting center saying
stop the couch
in pennsylvania and count the vote in
arizona
[Laughter]
what do we want justice when do we want
it not now
i mean trump's
trump's whole thing is like i've seen
some pretty low things
some pretty low tricks by the democrats
but counting all the ballots
that is a bridge too far of course he's
saying
it's a fraud and a hoax and he's suing
he's been telling us
he's going to do that for a year i've
been telling you for 3.
and yet
and yet the media is perpetually shocked
by this
they're like the announcer at a
wrestling match oh oh my god he's going
to hit him with a folding jam
yeah it happens all the time
a pundit on fox today said trump may
have the greatest moment of his career
bringing us together with his concession
speech really
because i'm picturing something more
like the end of scarface
concede
concede i'll be surprised if he comes
out of the bathroom
but look let's be gracious in victory i
just want to say mr trump if you are
watching as you do sometimes
accidentally
you may have lost the election but
there's one thing that you will always
have and that's the knowledge
that your father never loved you and
your mother had sex with an
ape
you